pas de nostalgie pour son anniversaire
pour ses 20 ans le medef regarde vers
l'avenir et pense à l'entreprise dans
deux décennies l'entreprise que nous
sommes aujourd'hui c'est décidé il ya 50
ans et on travaille à stabiliser et à
pérenniser l'entreprise pour les 50
prochaines années chez sodexo pour nous
l'entreprise séoul et c'est une
communauté c'est une communauté d
intérêts de ses actionnaires de ses
salariés de ses fournisseurs et de ses
clients
alors il est donc tout est décliné avec
en faisons en réalisant cette synthèse
une réflexion tournée vers le futur
choisi par le nouveau président du
mouvement élu en juillet dernier les
entreprises tournées vers l'europe les
nouvelles technologies l'intelligence
artificielle c'est un medef de
propositions la bnf qui va qui va
regarder les autres qui va proposer et
qui va être dans la concertation
on est aujourd'hui dans une économie de
confiance de confiance confiance avec
nos partenaires confiance avec les
politiques confiance avec les salariés
confiance et ça se bâtit on est dans un
monde qui bouge énormément
je pense que le grand groupe en lui même
les grands groupes tels qu'on les a
connus notamment en france vont être
amenés à bouger
ils vont peut-être changer énormément de
l'intérieur les start up sont en train
de grossir aussi donc elles vont aussi
venir sa ligne et plus de 4500
entrepreneurs ont répondu présent cette
année les syndicats ont profité de
l'événement pour se rassembler près de
200 d'entre eux contractés durant la
matinée du 29 août à l'entrée du campus
on a des propositions sur le statut de
l'encadrement le droit à la déconnexion
l'équilibré vie privée-vie
professionnelle l'égalité femmes-hommes
aussi qui est très une revendication
très importante voilà et puis à montrer
une présence montrer valaques yad'autres
d'autre choix possible que ce que
cherche à imposer le medef pour la
rentrée une intersyndicale appelle déjà
la mobilisation le 9 octobre pour
protester contre la politique sociale du
gouvernement